people of the internet retro wrecking
tour here I'm just a dad who loves games
and the stories they tell welcome back
to our Hogwarts Legacy dark arts
playthrough evil Slytherin Lord retro
Mort In the Flesh here ladies and
gentlemen
completely just
bald shaved head you got the scar on the
right side
part of his eyebrow is missing you can't
really see it at this angle but some
some Eerie yellow eyes
and we are continuing on with this play
through let me actually double check and
see what quest we have next in the
shadow of the Mind
so we are I would say over halfway at
this point
we are over the halfway mark and we also
stream this live over on Twitch so if
you guys are not following us over there
twitch.tv retro wrecking tour you will
see us here during this episode
interacting with a live audience uh and
probably talking a lot about drops with
our twitch audience because if you were
seeing this before June 2nd 2023
Avalanche has brought back the twitch
drops you can only get these
through twitch
and I'll show you them right now
actually if you go in and change your
appearance they are charms Professor
attire oh I actually wanted to test this
out guys so Ronan of course is a
Slytherin
oh man this these go perfect
with this robe set right here so this is
the Slytherin Relic house robe right
here
which I think just across the board the
The Relic house ahead of backwards The
Relic house uniforms are so good I think
they're best the best in the game and
Ronan of course is a Slytherin and I
thought these would go pretty well with
it and they totally do
they totally do it doesn't matter like
there's different shades of green in the
cloak and this this shade of green right
here like that stripe I feel like it
matches that perfectly and then you have
like the silver snake on there
but in addition to that the other drops
that you can get are the charms
Professor spectacles you know what we
should probably just go ahead and put it
on let's just put them all on that way
anybody who's asking we can be like
oh dude Lord retro Mort as the charms
Professor that is a terrifying oh we
already did that one and we got the Hat
we got the glasses the scarf as I
mentioned last time is probably my
favorite piece
you like the glasses Dustin yeah the
glasses are good
oh this is a good question here from
Rebo my favorite room
my favorite room in Hogwarts I might
have to think about that one the support
Crow
dude first time chatter
is that our Buddy Joe is that you Joe
no way that's a first first time chat
for Joe here no way
he's gonna be like oh no it's not Joe
it's somebody else
there's the robe
robe's pretty good too what's funny is
they said that obviously in the in the
main game Ronan doesn't have all of
these pieces so I don't think you see
him you don't see him wearing glasses
and you don't see him with a scarf and I
don't think he's wearing gloves either
so a lot of these they had to uh to kind
of make up and match to what what they
felt he would wear
and then you get the charms Professor
outfit right there
different account for
reasons
oh my gosh okay now I'm I'm curious like
you don't have to say here but let me
just say I'm very curious
I'm so curious about the reasons
all right Talent points we've got one to
spend
and I'm pretty sure I was saving it for
when we get AK we absolutely want that
and we may want that one at some point
as well let's see what is this one right
here an enemy under your control with
imperio curses other
we gotta do that one we gotta do that
one and we just got imperio last time
uh Tamaya
Alyssa to my Alyssa is that even close
sequence welcome in thank you all for
the follows appreciate it
Laura you gotta admit Lord retro ward
has got Style
oh so good Anna I love it yeah dude look
at look at Lord retro Mort right here
taken over for Professor Ronan as the
charms Professor I mean I am Slytherin
so the gloves
and the little uh
oh man I know there's a correct
technical name for this clasp I don't
think clasp is right but
all right let's move on to our Quest
here so in the shadow of the Mind meet
Sebastian by The Overlook
we might you guys I might just try to
beat the game tonight let's say you
Tamia oh man I was so close
so close
let's say you guys
I think we should try to beat the game
all right the good news here is I have
way more unlocked in terms of the flu
flames on uh this account oh and we've
got that one right here
so for those of you who tuned into our
last stream here on Twitch we basically
did play throughs with Ravenclaw and
Hufflepuff up to the point of the map
chamber just so we could get those
trophies and man it is painful not
having
all of the
all of the flu flames
it is just absolutely painful no flu
Flames no broom
it's really hard to do
hey intense aim welcome in dark arts
robes are the best oh dude you haven't
gotten the Relic House uniform yet
The Relic house uniforms are fire
all right so let's wait here
oh and I see White Mamba in the house as
well what's up
good to see you
all right Sebastian what do you got for
us as soon as I could so this is the
main mission occupied by all that
happened with ominous in the catacomb
not to mention my uncle's reaction that
had almost forgotten what it was that
struck me about that triptych this is
the view painted on the canvas that was
left on it that's incredible no Fast
Track you know this area well and while
I was waiting for you I scouted around
and discovered an abandoned mine nearby
surrounded by randwick's loyalists do
you think there's a connection to the
triptych I have no idea but perhaps
they're searching it the way they did
Brookwood castle and isadora's Manor
how do we want to handle this
we want to handle this oh we can yeah we
can definitely deal blows I think
catacomb I know right don't you love how
Sebastian or no no Sebastian
see this is what I've always wondered
about
such a tangent
about names
that so obviously in the U.S our version
of English we would say Sebastian
but if that person
lives in the UK and they say their name
is is Sebastian
then shouldn't we even though that's not
how we would like shouldn't you still
call them Sebastian
I thought about this when I made my
video on Sebastian
and I in that video I pronounce it
Sebastian
there's another YouTuber I watch a lot
his name is Ali abdall
he lives in London but he the way that
he uh he pronounces it Ali where we
would say Ali it's a-l-i
so I've always thought like shouldn't we
shouldn't we actually pronounce it
I say we take them head on or am I
thinking way too much about this very
well and I still Barnacle thank you for
the follow and impatient thank you for
the following connection I suspect we'll
see that symbol again
after you that's why you shorten it to
Seb right there we go makes everybody
happy let's call him Seb
whenever I mention Sebastian to my
friends they say don't you mean
Sebastian oh yeah yeah
I'm just saying like in real life like
if you actually like you need like if if
someone named Sebastian moved from the
UK
to the U.S and they're like hi I'm
Sebastian
I feel like that's what that's what you
should call them right
I'm thinking about it way too hard
aren't I
you're a wizard Harry
Tyrell with the sub
Ravenclaw Tyrell thank you so much
for the prime enjoy your ad free viewing
on the channel
all right I've got to get used to this
uh
I have a completely different setup on
this account
because on the other ones that I was
playing I didn't even have access to all
these spells yet
dude that wore off insanely quick
oh there's another one right there
I shouldn't have wasted that on him
this is hard mode as well so
I'm gonna have to be paying paying a lot
more attention than I was
on our other playthrough
oh I missed uh
there we go
no right before that incendio hit
come on Seb help me out
Rin welcome in Rin
you should pronounce the way someone
pronounces it see that's what I think
so like the fact that he is in the UK
and says Sebastian
I feel like we should we should call him
Sebastian
I have not played Jedi Survivor yet I
have played a fallen order
I'm waiting for all of the technical
issues to get ironed out
all the patches and updates that I'm
hearing they need to make on that game
all right let's go in here Overlook mine
finally where we're supposed to be
oh I missed a couple follows there too I
think uh bulls and lean leans Oak
welcome in welcome in the basketball for
us we're in
you think the UK win makes more sense
for
for Sebastian
you're a wizard Harry what is up it's
our buddy Dylan MCD three one three
Dylan happy Sunday my friend how's it
going
his mind looks like a tomb how's
everything going with the uh
the lead up to the big day
guys Dylan and his wife are expecting
their first child in about
how how much longer to go now I feel
like you guys are over the halfway point
right
and I mean these webs honestly with uh
with babies it's like once you make it
past that halfway point my wife's a
Nikki nurse and they see they see babies
I mean any time from like
I think 24 weeks is some of the earliest
they've seen before
is it's dead I mean she brought home one
of the diapers one time for how tiny
they are
it is amazing
but amazing what what they're able to do
to care for them
Dude That's so exciting man
I can't wait for you guys
hey the support Crow
with the sub thank you so much support
Crow I can't call you support crew I
have to call you Joe
you guys know
if you've been part of the Hogwarts
Legacy Community
you have probably seen one of his memes
Joe the crow there you go
uh Joe and Dylan oh wait wait wait Dylan
gifted that one to Joe let's go so Dylan
resubbed
and then Dylan gifted one over
to our Buddy Joe the support Crow
Dylan thank you for that gift itself
both you now enjoy your ideas
add free viewing
all right I think there was something
over here
small game table
all right what do you guys think about
the Arachnophobia mode
first of all anybody genuinely like
terrified of spiders in the chat
there's supposed to be another chest
somewhere
I didn't I don't need to use it but I
turned it on Just for just to see what
it looked like the other day
it is pretty funny and also kind of
terrifying I feel like at the same time
also a little bit terrifying
around here lumos to your biggest Fall
Guys rival whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what is this
we might have to get some Fall Guys
action going on the Stream
biggest Fall Guys rival
we have do we have two Fall Guys players
here
two or three memes
two or three
it's not one the spiders give people
Goosebumps
would be the hairy legs or the solar
signs or the venomous things or any
numbers don't forget all guys
between Todd D James Dylan and I
well wait where do I where do I where do
I take part in this is this like a
weekly thing
do we have like a high score list going
on here competing for crowns I need I
need more details here
hey Alexis welcome back
oh no way no way we're full on gear
slots I'm not sure what I did to deserve
that
I don't even know why I'm too worried
about I mean I guess I kind of do need
to worry about on this playthrough since
I'm gonna try and
see it through to the end
I do want to have some some decent gear
for in-game
oh let's see if there's anything yeah
we'll destroy that
okay that's an upgrade on offense
by two
yeah not worth
all right I'm just gonna dismantle those
two things
dismantle listen to me too much Destiny
back in the day
it's on James's Discord throw down on
The Fall Guys on Sundays
what
what how is I'm gonna I'm gonna have to
get on to James how is James never
invited me
I'm kidding I'm kidding so not not
stream just like offline just just you
guys having fun huh
that's cool
I haven't played Fall Guys in a while
though
I have not played Fall Guys in a while
I used to play a bunch of Fall Guys when
it first came out
gotta do the Merlin trials oh my gosh
I did all of them once
I'm just gonna keep hoping and praying
for a patch that finally fixes the
trophy for me
smashing should have thought to conjure
stairs hey Deborah welcome in no problem
happy to help yeah guys if you have any
questions on the drops exclamation point
drops we'll take you to the website that
lists all the steps everything you need
to do
you can get them by hanging out here
watching our stream with the exception
of the Merlin cloak so the Merlin cloak
that one is only available by watching
the official Avalanche stream
I don't think I have that equipped right
now I do not
thank you Dylan appreciate it
you got a beta Fall Guys code back in
the day
dude I don't even remember that how did
I get a
how did I get a beta cut
oh man here we go
there there you go seeing him in their
full Glory
no Arachnophobia mode here
that is the venomous scurrier right
there
let's see how many we got I think this
is the last one
nope nope nope I hear another one
I'm not sure what I did to deserve that
I thought I heard another one
bye wait where are you going Alexis
where are you going
just noticed Elwyn is in here I think L1
is is officially left us for D and D
guys
L Elwyn is a dungeon a full-time dungeon
master now
so
oh Alex is the same bye because of the
spiders I think
Professor Hackett would be proud oh man
all right all right all right here here
we could turn on if you guys want to see
I feel like a lot of people probably see
the Arachnophobia mode
follow the spiders
we should go and get this
thank you for the follow appreciate it
oh she's designing stuff crap
add that to her list huh
Owen is now graphic designer
all right there we go
okay we did clear up enough slots dude
look at that
see the eyes
oh my gosh that's not creepy at all
not creepy at all
this straight up horror movie I know
what the heck
is still fresh
yeah forget the spiders man look at that
Rebellion
Oh I thought there might be some fruits
out there
all right we gotta keep track I think we
have one more open slot
which as long as it's not a legendary
chest it's no problem
all right for anybody who hasn't seen
the Arachnophobia mode yet let's turn
that on
all you have to do is go into settings
and then it's under accessibility all
the way at the bottom
just switch it on there
and then they oh goodness there's one
right there
they got the roller skates no legs
just kind of this little floating
I don't even know what they look like
aliens or something
it's so strange
we've still not seen a single Rune
symbol I think we're going to be a bit
distracted from runes for a moment no
way inspector some distraction at that
on PC I'm assuming
we have another fight on our hands all
right here we go why am I not surprised
[Music]
all right
guys still up there
look there's one there's one right there
that one's kind of a got a green color
to it
of course the venomous matriarch
look at that they're purple
So based on which spider it is they're
slightly different colors because I
think earlier I had only seen
oh my gosh
I'd only seen one of them
and the little roller skates
crucio on a Spider-Man
two three
no the cooldown
there we go that attack right there is
so good the Transfiguration or transform
I guess it's called
hey geek Ledger welcome in I have not
seen it yet no
these days it's rare that my wife and I
get to the movies unless it's watching
uh watching something with the kids so I
usually have to wait until it get credit
until those things come out
on Blu-ray or digital fun to fight with
digital download I mean I was thinking
about that the other day what do people
say now
like for when a movie releases
because we used to say when it's out on
VHS didn't you say when it's out on DVD
then we'd say when it's out on Blu-Ray
now is it just like when it's when it's
available on digital platforms to buy
I've heard it's really good though I
have heard it's really good
honestly I don't think I've seen a
single bad thing about that movie
actually
everything I've read or seen online has
been very very positive
streaming yeah I guess streaming would
be that would work too
once it's available on streaming
all right so we've got this right here I
wonder if we're supposed to use that
to get somewhere and then we've got this
up here
that usually yeah I was gonna say
usually there are
more than one
I'm not sure what I did to deserve that
oh here we go that's where we need it
right here
no spoilers but well worth watching
Grand Rock's loyalists never knew to
look for it
levioso
the game you talking about the uh
Guardians of the Galaxy game I actually
have heard have heard yeah really good
things about the game too
Dustin
all right so let's see what's going to
be the best way to
I think we can hit that from I wouldn't
be surprised to find a couple oh yeah we
can hit all three of them from right
here one
two
and three
excuse me
did we miss one or is there a fourth
I think maybe we missed one
no not not that
all right what am I doing wrong you guys
I wasn't expecting that
what that was so strange
maybe it was the order
planning isadora's journal entry three
of seven
45 to 50 days to digital rental and
buying around another 80 to 90 days to
streaming
uh yeah I've I've been looking to see
when the Mario movie is gonna release
because my kids want to watch it again
so bad
we had such good time watching that in
theaters they have never asked to see a
move they actually asked to see it again
which we haven't been able to do yet but
the passageway
besides the room first
yes let's search the room first
Sebastian I think I found something yep
our efforts weren't in vain after all
still
something about this place feels odd
Rebellion there's something else we're
supposed to do
I don't think so I think we can go now
nope
oh wait talk to him
tryptic let us here to find this bit of
canvas we can probably assume that
Isadora Morgan Arc was here she seems to
have been everywhere but if she was
using the undercroft and the seller
beneath her Manor in feldcroft why would
she create this space and why hide it
behind cryptic Rune symbols and ancient
magic that no one but you could see is
Adora and Percival Rackham another of
the keepers could see traces of ancient
magic too raccoon
I haven't heard his name before his are
some of the memories I've seen
I don't think he and his Adora saw eye
to eye on how this magic should be used
this is all rather baffling he
definitely looks too nice the canvas
back with his clothing perhaps the
answers are there
he does not look like Lord retro more
with this attire on I'm fascinated by it
now by the way thank you for the new
follower welcome in
unless we can find another passageway to
the undercroft I think we got it right
here
and now for the moments of Truth oh yeah
the box office hall for Mario has been
incredible
absolutely incredible
please tell me you recognize the
location in this bit of canvas
the good news is I do in fact Sebastian
and the bad news
it's just for more trouble what the heck
he just walked right over that
I know that Coast Round Rock has taken
over a huge mine in the surrounding area
Marin weem has suffered for it it's as
bad as feldcroft's become should we head
there now we should wait any charms
Professor Justin we've been a step
behind run Rock
I may know someone who could help us get
ahead who is that
a friendly Goblin he wants no part in
ranrock's fight a friendly Goblin you
know goblins cursed my sister shut her
up I said you should be seen and not
heard I do but not all goblins not all
goblins what
have you forgotten feldcroft have you
forgotten the mind we just went through
no Sebastian I haven't you're not
listening to me why would I listen to
someone so ignorant
perhaps your uncle was right about you
you don't know when to stop oh I do know
when to tell I'm retro Mort
unbelievable
oh my goodness
all right yeah I think we've I think
we've rocked it enough for people to see
to get a good look guys if any of you
are watching right now these uh
everything I'm wearing right now those
are the drops which I think they're
better than the last drop for sure I
hope professor
as soon as you can
but overall I think this is way better
than the other drops which was like the
the urchin hat and I think it was just
some random things I don't think they
even went together
so I think this drop is for sure better
overall
but then I still think the Merlin cloak
is probably my favorite of all of them
all right for now I'm gonna keep these
gloves on because I think they go so
well with
everything else that I'm about to put on
here
all right so let's go with
no hat
probably no scarf too just because I
think with the house Relic
yeah scarf just doesn't look that great
with those
and then outfit I think I was using this
one yeah that's what we've been using
I feel like that goes
oh Professor you thought it looked like
Professor quarrel gotcha I could I could
see that
I could see a little bit of a professor
Coral there
all right let's see if we got our next
main quest we do the headmistress speaks
all right so this is neem Fitzgerald
and let's see where we need to go for
that one
probably the map chamber right
nope wrong one
secret rooms map chamber
I know Damia they they definitely
people are going to be asking for that
now for sure
and the fact that we already have
Professor black in game you you get that
one
so let's see we would need like uh the
Goblin's fig something
another repository they built drills to
help with their search sharp most
troubling garlic these repositories like
the broken container I found at Rookwood
Castle they are hey have a good one Wren
thank you for being here
have a look at the map
fortunately
Australia's first
as you know I was headmistress in my
time my portrait hangs in the
headmaster's office in fact I witnessed
Professor black learn of your arrival
I'll confess that I wondered about you
wait is the next trial yeah it's a good
one it is
I had hopes this is a good one occupant
of that office would be of help to us
unfortunately this Headmaster seems
wildly unconcerned with anything but
himself
you'll need to access the office while
he's away I understand
very well I'll find some way to get in
good I shall meet you in my portrait
there until then
you shall meet me in the portrait all
right I'm trying to remember how this
Quest plays out I know we have to talk
to
we talked to Fig oh we gotta wait for it
to pop up I guess
how will I gain access to the
headmaster's office
perhaps Professor fig will know what to
do
see I think it would be cool if they
gave you multiple ways to do this one
like what if we could imperio somebody
if you're going down the dark path
just just let it let him do imperio
oh that could be cool Joe that could be
really cool
I really can't wait to see what what
they decide to do next
because they they really do have so many
so many different options for things
they could try I don't know if I want to
do that yet
uh I mean let's just go ahead and do it
why not right
Aloha Mora I don't even know if it's
gonna matter because
the only way this all matters is if I
have to end up
if I have to end up doing everything
again
for the platinum trophy
on a different playthrough
they're spoiled for Choice what do you
mean like they'd have to decide they
have to decide like what they want the
Canon ending to be for their game yeah
all right so we got that page
I was so disappointed when that didn't
that should have totally moved
when you grab that
it would have been such a great jump
scare
because it looks like I mean you see
that and you're thinking okay that's
totally gonna do something when I get
close right
like not that it comes to life but that
it just like like the arm falls off or
something
oh man it would have been so funny
Canon ending is almost always the good
one
for this game dude I feel like they I
feel like
they I shouldn't say they wanted you to
play evil but I feel like your character
making the bad choices and going into
the dark arts
I think that's what they intended for
the quote unquote Canon
which who knows if they've even decided
that sort of thing but
just seeing the way it all plays out
particularly with Sebastian's Quest
or Sebastian I should say
man I think it was definitely more
intended
because the way that one ends we were
talking about this uh
what are we talking about this
oh it was on this playthrough this
playthrough of the game because I'm
making you know I'm making the evil
choices on this one so seeing how it
plays out when you get imperio
I had no idea that when you're making
the evil choices you actually the player
character you cast imperio on ominous
and you actually see more
remorse from Sebastian there
than you ever do when you make the other
choices which I I just found that I
found that fascinating
that
when you make all like the good choices
alohomora Seb is just a pretty
not a not a good dude for most of the
game he's got good intentions a lot of
times
but
but then when you make the bad choices
so it's like in this weird way
you making the bad choices almost ends
up
what do we have here making Seb a little
bit more remorseful
even though I mean it
the end game still kind of plays out the
same unfortunately which I think it
would have been cool if it didn't like
if you actually
had a chance to impact how that final
section plays out with him
in a more prominent way than than you
end up doing in the game
try not to give too much away to people
who haven't played it all the way
through yet to see
all right is there anything else we need
to get in here
foreign
yeah Joe you're right on like the the
big the well it's not even big like you
said it's not a huge deal the the main
choice that you make for the ending and
whatnot
doesn't even really affect that much I
think the Seb choice is by far the more
impactful one if they go for a direct
sequel
it's by far the more impactful one wait
did I already must have already gotten
this so where is the other
is there one here
because it it plays out very differently
based on the choice you make there
oh yeah yeah if you cast lumos by the
tapestries
yeah I made a I made a video about that
a couple videos I made a short video
about it and then I think I included it
in one of my
larger videos too but yeah if you if you
cast lumos in that room in front of each
of the tapestries you can like see the
full the full story
imagine SQL where Seb becomes the
antagonist
exactly
because if you make the good well
I don't want to spoil too much if people
haven't played play through that part I
don't want to spoil it for them but
it's like in a weird way making the good
choice
they what I felt was like supposed to be
the good choice they make you feel like
that was actually the wrong like the bad
choice
that's how I felt anyway
it's so it's so interesting like
that that choice specifically Sebastian
is by far
the most interesting in the whole game I
feel like in terms of the choices you
make
skip to seventh Year and have young
Dumbledore give us a quest
maybe maybe a lot of people would like
that I almost feel like they don't want
to do that though I feel like they
actually
like the idea of just being able to tell
their own story and Dustin I actually
think that's why they changed the date
on the daily profit
to give them a little more wiggle room
so remember when the first trailer that
showed that daily profit
um front page of course we all
immediately picked it apart and started
talking about that date and how that
meant Okay then if we get to a year
seven Dumbledore has to be there then in
the final version of the game though if
you look back at that same scene no date
on the daily profit now I know people
have found some letters and notes in the
game
I hope that uh do have dates on them but
the next trial is I think they may have
wanted to take those out actually
waiting for another repository like the
one we saw at Rookwood castle and I
discovered that they're building massive
drills to help in their search Professor
Fitzgerald seemed very concerned I see
I'll leave with it despite orders from
Round Rock I don't know what to say
she could win over almost anyone I want
to hear more of this and in fact I'd
like to speak with lodgok directly Lord
God we've no time now where is the next
trial believe it or not
it's in the headmaster's office
incredible
all right you will need the password to
get past the stone gargoyle the
headmaster's house elf will know it I
love how fig is just totally on board
with this sure he'll tell me he's rather
devoted family he is so you'll need a
disguise I have just the thing apolly
juice potion even gives you the
conversation like Professor black wait
doesn't Polly juice potion require a bit
of the person you want to change into
and take ages to brew it does so how do
you already have Polyjuice Potion to
change into Professor black good
question the thing may come in handy
let's just say I felt the need to be
prepared for anything after my fruitless
trip to the ministry on his behalf now
time is of the essence drink up and I
shall explain more
here we go man it's one of the coolest
missions in the game by the way yeah
Elwyn chat was asking about you earlier
Marielle was so disappointed you weren't
here and I was glad I was told him I
said guys I think we've lost Elwyn
forever elwin is a full-time
uh what do you call it DM now l1's a
full-time dungeon master do you feel
she's gone incredible she won't be back
I won't forget that taste anytime soon
how do I sound convincing I've taken the
liberty of transfiguring your robes
let's go disgust you'll need the
password from scrope who could be
anywhere in the castle
you might look for Professor Kagawa
music
in the hopes that he can convince black
to change his mind
thus far unsuccessfully I see
but what if Professor black sees me
leave him to me I shall tell him where
to meet a liaison from the ministry in
hogsmead that should give you plenty of
time thank you Professor I suppose we'll
meet again in the map chamber it's
rather strange to hear gratitude coming
from Professor black I'll see you there
now to find the headmaster's house
health I also love how people kind of
found out about this before the game
ever came out when they remember when
they released that video with Simon Pegg
making the announcement that he was
voicing black
there was like a moment where you could
zoom in close to see
what what he was reading
and
it said something like
I can't remember what exactly it said
but it was something that basically
told us like wait is he
he's under Paula juice
so a lot of us uh
thought that might be where things were
heading
and there's so many people you can talk
to and oh wait that's Sebastian right
there
I can't believe he doesn't comment or
say anything
Professor a moment of your time please I
wish you could just walk by him
something to catch you I I
um places to be Professor shop places
yes that's right inspector yes you asked
me about a particular potion and I
Professor black and then in parentheses
player
really best not to discuss it here sir
I assure you shop you may speak freely
very well I've brewed the cure for boils
you wanted I can drop it by your office
when it's convenient
of course yes no need for all the Cloak
and Dagger simply have a student deliver
it a student
very well sir if you insist I do and
thank you sharp I just hope you've
brewed enough for all my boils
now to determine which student gets this
rather unenviable task
s
the future is yours
all of my boils I know right the main
character getting a little uh
pushing the limits there
let's see you can talk to Gareth
dude I wonder if you're has anybody ever
tried going to oh I bet it says you're
like going out of bounds or something
doesn't it like can I even travel to
other areas right now
no you can't
see like if if you were playing as a
Gryffindor and then you tried to go as a
Slytherin or something tried to get into
the Slytherin common room it wouldn't oh
did you try it Dustin
I was about to say I know somebody's had
to try that
yeah you can't even you can't even cast
spells right now either you can do that
all the little holiday decorations
you're cold that's a shine on those
boots do better
yeah what could he want
I'm gonna talk to almonds Mr gaunt where
do you think you're going I beg your
pardon sir I'm simply on my way outside
you used to be able to leave typical
student wasting the hours away I I have
to write 20 inches on dittany and its
uses was heading to the greenhouse black
in Disguise is what it says
tuba pus makes a a fine uh mustache
paste yes mustache paste uh I find are
you feeling all right sir you don't seem
yourself I assure you I am quite healthy
good if I need a medical diagnosis I
shall head to Saint Mungo go all the way
to hogsmead oh my goodness before they
patched it something is very wrong with
professor
it is not too late to reconsider your
decision regarding quidditch we we could
still have trials and a somewhat
shortened season it would be better than
none at all but the injury Madame Kagawa
professor more than one student has
taken a bludger to the head on our pitch
that it happened to be a pure blood well
that's no reason to what nonsense that
you would trivialize the health of a
student over a silly game a silly
you you are quite impossible sometimes
sir
I have a good mind director the
department of magical games and sports
at the ministry about you
so let's go ahead and finish this
conversation here with Madame kangawa
remember I'm playing as as dark arts
like evil playthrough so I'm trying to
be just just a jerk on this playthrough
all right so she said I have a good mind
to write to the Department of magical
games and sports at the ministry about
you
I'm gonna say oh dude this one's like
with him you know they're both gonna be
this one's just like dripping with
sarcasm I think I'm gonna do this one
good idea
I can even provide the parchment should
you need it now where is my elf I
patchment
that's right
and I spotted scorp in the Great Hall
seems to be avoiding me hmm I wonder why
good day Madame Kagawa
yeah you if you go to the Great Hall
yeah we'll get to see it here
you can change the the decorations out
of my way children
I don't think I remembered though that
you can't actually cast you can't cast
any spells when you're him no revelio
can't even do revelio
like how funny would it be if you could
just run over here and just start
start yelling at all the students be so
funny
Miss broom a word oh try to jump off the
wall interesting surprise
spells
become one that makes me disappear we'll
keep at it broom and before you know it
you'll be as invisible as that new fifth
year seems to be They're Not Invisible I
mean I've seen them about I mean yes sir
speaking of invisible where's my blasted
house elf
why can't we give out detention dude
imagine
all right hold on I want to try to do
this Alexis said you're off with the
Headmaster I know right we just stitched
our I feel like when you're when you're
uh
poly juicing as him the main character
we see a completely different side of
the main character right here wait why
do you want me to try to jump off here
wouldn't I wouldn't I just die right
here
jump off the wall up a level
the left of Kagawa
you guys somebody was saying that they
patched where you can't actually
there's a binge by the half wall that
you can jump off there oh
right here maybe
oh like if you wanted to get out with
him
oh he's definitely getting high enough
but it won't it's not sending him off
only a couple of times interesting
and then what happens once you do can
you actually run around go different
places with him or does it reset you or
something
oh wait we need to go this way
yes you you will die
dying as Professor black
line we got to hear from Simon Pegg when
they first announced that he was voicing
the camera ah
um speak with you about I feel like she
would know
almost right away I've decided to give
him there's some poly juice
with his time Moon spark what is up
welcome in twice
I confess I do worry for his students
he's rarely here as it is
and I don't miss him I realize that and
I'd like to keep it that way I see
but sir if I do I am wary of how much
time to jump on the bench I know he's
spending away from the castle supposedly
on Professor Fig's behalf I've heard
unsettling rumors of their escapades
everything from sneaking into the
Forbidden Forest to confronting Rand
Rock's Loyalists and rookwood's lot what
goodness you cannot believe everything
you hear Professor no no no no you
cannot I mean I shall keep an eye on fig
you simply keep doing the wonderful job
that you're doing simply she is so not
convinced
thank you
but I'm happy to look good good that'll
be always late I mean Professor Weasley
good day thank you for the follow
welcome in
a wonderful job leeway for Professor fig
I shall never
so maybe he's just so off the wall and
erratic Professor most of the time
anyway
that none of this is a surprise for
anybody
a little scrope
true yeah sharp you think he would know
but Master might scrub swear never to
tell anyone even Master himself
dare question how dare you question me I
have a mind to give you a matching set
of ears uh yes sir of course a scope
begs forgiveness it is the black family
motto Master hmm right
of course I uh
that that could be true too most people
just don't talk to him enough
it's to do with
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait hold on
purity of blood right
no family's reign of course I remember
it's the black family Reigns is Master
giving scrope a test oh no it is the
blood one darn it I forgot it's kill
Bloods forever isn't it a close Master
scrap things indeed always pure yes yes
it is
always pure
of course as Master knows uh Ray no I've
never seen that one what system are you
on yes of course
[Music]
French is most pitiful
oh very well
there is another matters group I
confiscated this filthy diary from a
student it smells of squid and seawater
oh the apollonia's dying that's a
different line of dialogue he's quite a
surprise you play as a Slytherin what do
you wish grout to do with this treasure
the rubbish whatever you wish screw it's
your treasure oh that's that's pretty
interesting actually
so scrope gets to keep it when you uh
apologies potions wearing off attention
I hereby decree that the Great Hall
before
banners or of Slytherin I shall be
taking no questions at this time oh ever
oh my goodness dude
all right they said it's starting to
wear off
as he burps on the way out
Hey Joe thanks for being here dude good
to see you
have a good rest of your night hope you
get a good night's sleep
return what are you talking about I
thought I was where it was supposed to
be
oh wait it wants me to go this way
oh come on move
thought I was supposed to leave sorry
I don't know why it makes me walk so
slow through there
wait what in the world
you guys can tell I have not done this
in a while okay all the way over here
here we go
I made it just in time it's wearing off
interact
I think was right I can't believe it
worked Blue Dog what's with the now to
speak the password yeah I'm not sure I'm
not sure what the uh
what the numbers are supposed to mean or
the hashtag
all right so now we know the password
uh I don't even really care about that
right now
K with the follow okay welcome in thank
you for the follow
all right now
now we go back out this way okay
yeah I just forgot about the part we're
supposed to go up there and change
oh look at that emote from K there
the cat with the glasses nice
all right let's go all the way to the
top
or a wizard Harry yo Dylan
dude I didn't even know you were still
here Dylan Dylan with five more gifted
Subs right there you're a wizard Harry
guys if you just got one of those
gifteds make sure you think Dylan enjoy
your ad free viewing that is by far I in
my opinion the biggest benefit to being
a you get gifted a subscription or
become a sub yourself on Twitter
is ad free viewing whenever you're
watching the channel
Dylan thank you so much appreciate it my
friend
oh yeah and you also get access to some
pretty cool emotes as well they may just
spamming one of them right there
yes indeed
no no we're full on that again
gotta be kidding me
as cop Stones I gotta be honest with you
guys
I gotta be honest not on this
playthrough anyway
yeah there's a bunch right here
Mirabelle garlics herbology award
wait where's
that one sounds really close
oh man there's a gobstone right there
I mean it's right there guys hope Sons I
have to grab it it's right there
Paul thank you for the follow welcome in
I better keep an eye on high places
around the school for zenobius gulp
stones
Rebellion
dude it sounds like I was about to say
it sounds like it's right beside me
how self armor
and Iron Age
with the follow as well
I is that I or l
I oh wait wait Immortal JKR maybe maybe
is that it Immortal Jake AR
thank you for the follow welcome in
is the minimap new no it's not it's not
new unless they I don't think they made
any tweaks to it in the latest update
I did in my first playthrough I actually
played with the mini map off a lot
you can disable it
in the accessibility but no it's it's
enabled by default
Wyatt deal two with the follow thank you
thank you revelio
all right hold on I want to get that one
where is it
in here
oh my gosh in my headphones it sounds
like it's just it's right beside
that's where I need to speed the pause
one I still hear another one
maybe it's up there in the room
all right let's speak the password
close enough oh man I knew I wouldn't
get it right
super ninja okay I can get that one
super ninja with the follow
thank you my friend welcome in Wonder of
all the elite Wizarding families have a
motto if you guys have any questions at
all about the stream or about the drops
uh the drops we do have a command set up
exclamation point drops we'll get you
the information that you need
oh a nice wand handle there
and we do have drops enabled here
it's good to see you yes we made it
that's a fixed quick thinking really
really cool missions coming up the
pedestal so this is a good timing and
read the book that appears
find in the book what can I expect to
find in the book a story
I cannot say more
you may recognize some elements of it as
I was inspired by a tale with which many
Wizarding children are familiar
aaronage aaronage ah I suspect there
will be more to this than reading a book
your suspicions are correct we shall
speak when you are finished
has this been under the headmaster's
nurse all this time
okay
Apothecary receipt cure for boils
one file oh my goodness
I will help myself to a bit of tea there
it is Sorting Hat
I know
Star Wars I agree
and then and then the final trial is
just after this one it's a bit of a
letdown that's I mean that must be the
pedestal I actually had to be reminded
of what the final trial was by uh
when we did our big uh live stream
with expecto go and was your PhD
and uh let's see who else was there
Miranda lorian wizard tricks and then
Benjamin snow couldn't make it that
night but they had to remind me I was
like wait what was the last one where am
I
Professor Fitzgerald oh this is epic man
this one's so good here
in this place
on hogsby yeah haunted Hog's meat is
good too
you shall be witness to a fable pay
attention
things are not always as they seem
S I think swiftly hold on as soon as she
stops talking this place doesn't Life
Death takes many forms I look at each of
them at all costs we'll get this
foreign
yikes
oh dude he does look somebody said I
look very Voldemort now
I mean this character is Lord retro Mort
here we are going for the full
dark arts oh wait I can't change my gear
right now I wanted to dismantle some
things oh well that's fine
but I think what stands out about quests
like this one and the haunted hogsmead
is just they're so unique
like this I would even count the first
first mission of the game like Gringotts
and all of that
I wish they would have had more time to
do to do more quests like that because
they they all three just
stand out
interesting that has a lock on there
Dylan have a good one dude thank you
again for the gifted subs and all your
support
all right I am on hard mode this time so
I don't know if it's
more difficult to get through the
stealth stealth sections on this part or
not
oh geez
Ryu thank you for the follow welcome in
is that going for now
I need to get out of here
why couldn't he be even the music it's
so ominous here
oh wait
I need to time this just right
any DLC to get more unique missions like
these for real for real
let's go
I think my favorite part of this one is
is toward the end
okay straight ahead
wait a staircase straight ahead
oh wait I gotta go now I didn't know he
left
thank you
dad
first time you watch my streams
well quidditch I think we know is not
happening now
because they're making a
dedicated games
Harry Potter Quidditch champions
and then try wizard they could do that
but they would have to set it in a
different time period
but I've said it even earlier
in the in the Wizarding World lore to
make it fit
death's dark mongrel okay can we go
through here
nope we cannot
but there is the ladder right there
I mean just the art alone
just just that subtle change
it's also a great nod to the movie too
which I mean the movies you know they
didn't get everything right
but I think one of the things they
nailed is the tale of the Deathly
Hallows and how they told that story
the Del Ponta with the 20
Musa
be Del Pont thank you so much
for the 20 months here as a subscriber
enjoy your ad free viewing and you also
get access to all of our fun Wizarding
World emotes
oh yeah Neve I think I said neem earlier
fast as I can
all right wait for it now
move why are you going so slow
he was going so slow
that's where I need to go but I
I find a way past
a wait for it
foreign
creeped you out
yeah I mean it is definitely I think
they I think that's what they were going
for for sure
have you played Haunted Hogs me though
Haunted Hogs meat is
creepier than this
yeah I'm hoping the Quidditch game is
good too
I definitely think it's the right move
to make it make a dedicated Quidditch
game oh [__] you're getting past them
that way
I don't remember what I'm supposed to do
here I'm just going in this room
I don't know if this is right
I think it is I think it is
yeah I think it's the right move to make
a dedicated Quidditch game because of I
mean to really do quidditch right
I think that's the only way to do it
oh man are you kidding me we have to go
through here
I don't remember this part
that was my chance
Master oh my gosh he's so slow right now
and then he speeds up I don't get that
I'm not sure why
I think it's part of the mission
oh also erase stormy night and sporadic
with the follows thank you all welcome
to the Stream
hope you are having a good evening
morning afternoon whatever it may be in
your part of the world
all right here we go
a mysterious cloak you guys
that's right not just a disillusionment
charm now
oh yeah I think we can just walk right
by them now they can't see me at all I
can get closer to them
the power
of a Deathly Hallow my friends
this is the way forward
finally free
where are you Neve
chocolate and ice cream man you guys
gonna get me hungry
dude look at him
yes you will be unable to hide
look at that you guys recognize that
do not squander it's
I wonder if she'll get mad at me for
using unforgivables
it's upset by that
I don't know but we're about to find out
that was such
pop yes indeed at the Elder Wand
oh wait
oh wait can I not oh I don't even have
access to them right now
huh
so it automatically sets you up with
those bells
see I didn't even have unforgivables on
my first playthrough so
did not remember that Rebellion
I know
I wish it would be so crazy to see if we
could
dude just look at the basic shot
go ahead
it's kind of like Haunted Hogs me too I
feel like the spell effects are even
more exaggerated
colors are brighter or maybe it's just
because everything else is black and
white around it so it makes them pop
even more
carpet with the follow thank you thank
you welcome in
man you guys who hopped into the stream
recently jumping in at a great time
you can see what
ancient Magic
and you also it looks like you refill
refill pretty quick too
on your ancient magic meter
dude it didn't even pop off
and I still got the protago in there
all right let's use a wiggin well just
to be sure
it is getting a little bit overwhelming
right now
oh no all right
oh bombard is just destroying
we cannot die with the Elder Wand you
guys I don't care if it is on hard mode
we cannot die with the Elder Wand in our
hands
[Applause]
there we go
I agree TTV
Ali yeah I I love this game
oh that's another good idea Star Wars
boy yeah like if you could replay
and see I feel like that's something
that should be relatively I mean I I
hesitate to call anything easy because
I'm not a game developer I don't know
what it would take
but it's something that's already in the
game obviously so it wouldn't take as
many resources as doing something
completely new
so I've said for a while I think like a
new game plus photo mode
maybe uh enabling
like crossed ones
and oh what's the other game with uh
summoner's court and then like your idea
right there I think all that would be
good for like a free DLC and then of
course hopefully we'll get
actual full-on new content DLC as well
oh my goodness
control was not messing around
geez
wow they hit hard in this
spot right here
no
all right we gotta get rid of him
I'm waiting I'm waiting for another uh
protego moment
there we go
oh I missed that one
there we go get stupefy on him
this should take him out right here
yep
another one no way dude
wait did the Stupify Miss what the heck
I don't know what happened there
he just go
es that is too funny Defender
purple
the window
I didn't take damage but somehow it
missed
Defender
oh I got hit by him as he was trying to
go in for the counter
there we go
I still like all this time later
over well over 100 hours into this game
I am still having such a blast with the
combat
just hasn't gotten old for me
oh we got so many guys around us right
now
Defender
yeah this might be my favorite mission
I I wasn't sure after one playthrough
but playing through it again now
I think it might be my favorite Mission
this is so good
all right just to be sure just to be
sure
[Applause]
there we go got rid of him wait what
how's he still up
okay now he's now he's down now he's
down
Defender
oh out of nowhere
we were almost dead
had to get that quick wiggin weld right
there oh I timed it too early
all right hold on we can we can finish
him off
I think there's one more over here yep
this guy right oh two okay
get a little ancient Magic
is that it
by the way uh Evil Goat Jay Spyro aravin
Jim thank you all for the follows
welcome in welcome in
okay that was fun
do I think it'll be Game of the Year nah
probably not
I think I think Zelda will probably win
game of the year
that is my guess just from a lot of the
early impressions
but we shall see you never know
BH Stone boxy girl thank you for the
follow welcome in
yo Stargazer Tim what is up dude Tim
with the late night hours
that's right you liked Stampley don't
you Tim this must be for me
monkey Birds what is up
mysterious Stone
mysterious Stone whatever could it be
you are far from finished
far from finished
okay so this is when she
after she died
foxy girl if you play any play Hearts
Legacy is there any music
uh
uh no actually I haven't gotten hit with
any
any copyright issues without works
Legacy no but you cannot undo what has
been done
the magic of the stone can only conjure
a shadow of my former self
there was a song
gosh in the lead up to the game
that appeared in one of the trailers
that
it was getting uh copyright
um not not striked but there's no light
with that question on YouTube
simply because you can eliminate
Darkness
does not always mean that you should
but everything with the game has been
totally fine for me and their Community
manager Chandler wood is really good
about
looking into that stuff if it ever if it
ever did happen remember he told us at
one point he could reach out and
let him know so
yeah I haven't had any problems with
with the game itself
memes or a Neve is how you pronounce it
excited for Star field
I'm like
I'm cautiously optimistic for Starfield
I know Zelda's gonna be good
Starfield it's like it should be good
but
everybody had relatively big hopes for
red fall too and that
and
from what I've heard is not not too hot
oh yeah all the beetle Bard stories are
great it's been it's been a while since
I've read through them all though
yeah exactly Tim would you
exactly
I'm Percival needs to worry about the
strands of emotion or the traces oh yeah
this is a really big moment right here I
found a way to get
hey what's up mister Mr h
worry he has no idea what we're
containing
and as it happens I do know it is a
source of strength of focus
somehow it enhances my ability to wield
Magic
I don't follow it's Adora I think we can
harness it power like this is not to be
toyed with in the wrong house look at
what I did for my father
yeah imagine yeah because where it
really hits the fan some kind of pain
what are you doing
all right the tin
Can you feel it this is when you see
that she's like she's too far gone now
all of us
you've kept this power to yourselves for
so long because you fear it
I choose to embrace it
I don't think it's a Time Turner no
no you can see it's like a little uh
Emerald there
I remember uh expecto go I can't
remember if you did a video about it but
I know he talked about it on a stream at
some point
whether or not it could potentially be
one
man that is such a cool Mission those
fights at the end almost wish they would
introduce a new enemy right at the end
though
like I know you get it's kind of like an
alternate version of the trolls and some
other things but
I feel like it should have been
something else you know like uh
I don't know a a dragon or
just some other type of creature
that emerges there at the end could have
been really cool
oh fig what's up dude
we're back
is it true
has someone
oh he's wearing one too look at that
similar looking it is you and I have but
you are so young I know
you must be Professor Bacall I am
pleased to meet you
the pensive memory I just witnessed was
Isador inhaling painful emotions
inhaling
it was I was amazing to see that it
seemed to give her some sort of power
and that she could harness I Am Lord
retro more afterwards wow that you seem
more intrigued than repulsed I hesitate
to reveal the location of my pensive to
someone who perhaps has yet to
understand the responsibility of power
or we understand Professor I do in fact
what you don't yet know is that a
dangerous Goblin called vanrock has
accessed the repository at Rockwood
Castle he has learned to harness the
contents of it as a source of immense
power he plans to use that power against
him or some other death creature like a
giant
could have been cool nonetheless the
knowledge you shall gain after you
witness my memories is too valuable to
share without further consideration
I shall require time to confer with the
other keepers
that would have been a great moment for
you to learn teams we have no choice
frustrating as it
Isadora was inhaling emotions to gain
power she was and she pulled emotions as
she did from her father from Professor
Fitzgerald without without permission
what's more she said that she found a
way to stall the traces of magic she
extracted in Goblin silver the
repositories possibly
there's something I didn't get a chance
to tell you earlier
ran Rock has been digging at locations
tied to the five names he found in the
journals worker named bragbull five
names
yep he knows Isadora morgenack precisely
that's how he's been one step ahead of
us Gringotts the tower Rookwood castle
if the keepers won't tell you where the
next trial is yet I say we at least
maintain a watch on ran Rock perhaps
he'll lead us to more information
perhaps I hope to hear from Lord [__]
soon
I haven't heard anything since I learned
of the drills oh and as you've probably
guessed by now your poly juice marked
like a charm I knew it would I may have
done too good a job distracting black I
had no idea he can't hold his fire
whiskey
you didn't know Victor Chrome was in the
1890s hey this is uh this is Lord retro
Mort here
Lord retro Mort